Let's take a quick look at using Cloud SQL
with App Engine.
The first step is to create a database.
Go to the SQL section and click create instance
and choose "second generation."
Give your instance a name, and then choose
the region and zone for your instance.
You can now change the instance type and the
storage capacity.
Don't worry, you can change these later if
you want to.
You can also ensure high availability by creating
failover replicas, and you can schedule backups
and maintenance windows as well.
Click "Create," and in a few minutes your
instance should be created.
You can see all your instance details on this
page.
Now, go to the access control tab and then
go to the users tab.
Specify a new root password.
In your app.yaml, create an environment variable
section with the following information.
Use the instance connection name from the
overview page and specify a database name
and root password.
It's important to create a database and table
before using it with App Engine.
You can use these environment variables to
connect to your Cloud SQL database just like
any other MySQL database.